[Musica]
Ma dove sono
ma che diavolo
non funzionano gli spara ragnatele
Ma che cosa aspetta
questo fighissimo ma nasconde qualcosa
[Musica]
devo capire dove sono
che cosa io
[Musica]
Fatevi sotto cattivoni siete finiti
nella mia ragnatela
Sì credo che funzioni come frasi ad
effetto
un momento ma qui il mio dispositivo
Cerca cattivi da altri universi non
rileva alcuna anomalia Che strano Forse
si è rotto
ho capito Ned avrà di nuovo sbagliato
con il portale Io glielo avevo detto che
doveva esercitarsi di più con la magia
ma ovviamente era troppo impegnato con
le vacanze estive e con la sua nuova
fiamma il solito Ned
bei tempi quando Ned era un po' più nerd
Ok Questa era brutta Meno male che sono
da solo e non mi ha sentito nessuno Ehi
ciao Ciao a tutti Eh allora non ero solo
bella figura Peter come al solito eh
Ciao ragazzi ciao come state Tutto bene
ho detto
Sì grazie grazie ma vi ho chiesto una
cosa Come state Tutto bene
sono il vostro arrampicamori di
quartiere e sono qui in missione lo
sapete io sono qui perché sto cercando
di rimettere a posto alcune cosette dopo
quel piccolo problema con il multiverso
sapete
Lo sapete che è l'insieme degli universi
paralleli al nostro Ognuno dei quali si
trova confinato in un sistema di
inflazione eterna con variazioni
costanti differenti tra loro e insomma
vabbè non è una figata assurda ok
scusate non volevo annoiarvi Però magari
voi Potete aiutarmi sapeste per caso
dirmi dove siamo esattamente qui
Non ho capito dove siamo qui ragazzi
Barletta ne ho sentito parlare e ditemi
Avete visto qualcosa di strano in giro o
qualche super Cattivo che semina il
panico
Ah no
non l'avete visti neanche uno io sono
venuto qui apposta Vabbè allora è tutto
tranquillo Dovrò comunque dare
un'occhiata e intanto faccio un rapporto
al signor Fury Datemi un secondo eh
pronto Salve Nick scusi volevo dire
Signore Sì sono io certo la missione
procede bene Sì sì sì dove sono in
Italia signore Sì a Barletta Sì è un
posto bellissimo piano di spiagge mare e
cibo buonissimo Sì sì me l'hanno detto
delle simpatiche persone che sono qui
Certo certo Sono qui davanti a me ma
come ologrammi No non sono ologrammi non
sono illusioni e nemmeno degli alieni Le
garantisco che sono persone vere dei
terrestri dico bene ragazzi facciamo
sentire un urlo più forte al signor
fiori se no non ci crede uno due tre
una festa No no no non è una festa
signore davvero sono solo in missione ho
solo un po' di compagnia tutto qui in
effetti visto che ci siamo non sarebbe
male fermarsi un momento per mangiare
qualche Panzerotto e fare un po' una
festicciola Vabbè comunque sì signore Ok
ok ho capito prudenza e profilo basso Va
bene va bene certo non darò nell'occhio
Eh no no no no Scusi signore intendevo
non intendevo prendere in giro davvero
Era solo una battuta era un modo di dire
dare nell'occhio sai no pronto pronto
Mi sa che si è offeso Vabbè allora darò
un'occhiata qui in giro devo assicurarmi
che siano tutti al sicuro sapete perché
quando si riesce a fare le cose che
faccio io se non le fai e poi succedono
cose brutte succedono per casa tua
perché da un grande potere derivano
grandi responsabilità
e quindi Stavo dicendo che
che succede Heidi Ciao
non sai più parlare
è successo
sai che sei strano senza voce
non sembri più tu vero Sì la figura però
non sei più così amichevole sei più così
spavaldo Insomma fai le battute
Mi dispiace non riesci più a parlare
potrebbe esserci chiunque lì sotto
insomma ecco non sembri tu comunque
guarda c'è una missione per te ci sono
altri supereroi che ti stanno aspettando
corri corri corri Sbrigati devi salvare
delle persone Salutiamo il nostro Spidi
ce ne siamo liberati no poverino
Ciao a tutti Mi presento Sono Alex
Polidori sono un doppiatore e qualcuno
mi conosce per aver dato la voce a quel
personaggiono lì e nelle ultime
apparizioni cinematografiche non in
tutte e
niente Sono molto felice di essere qui
perché volevo
parlarvi della voce perché la voce per
me è veramente vita e poi ve lo
spiegherò dopo il perché
tutto quello che so fare ruota intorno
alla voce canto recito e forse non so
fare nient'altro però
volevo farvi capire come
che cosa è successo qui un personaggio
così iconico no che Tutti conoscono i
grandi e Piccini lo amano tutti privato
della sua voce meno la voce che tutti
conoscete almeno qui in Italia
la mia
diventa strano non sembra più lui perde
un po' l'espressività perde la sua anima
vista anche la maschera non ha
espressione quindi la voce gioca un
ruolo fondamentale sembra un po' quasi
privo di un suo superpotere nonostante
le grandi doti atletiche Anzi facciamo
un altro applauso aspide che ha avuto
fatto delle cose bellissime
e però perde un po' no perché senza
quello strumento che possiamo utilizzare
tutti noi che noi doppiatori utilizziamo
sempre per tirare fuori tutto quello che
è nella nostra anima e per trasmettere
emozioni e si chiama voce
i personaggi forse non prendono vita
come dovrebbero prenderla
e la voce probabilmente è il primo suono
che ascoltiamo quando siamo non neonati
proprio quando siamo nel ventre materno
Mi viene da dire oddio Forse nessuno lo
può sapere però secondo me la voce dei
nostri genitori la ascoltiamo un po' e
cominciamo già a familiarizzarci e
quando nasciamo la voce è il simbolo
della vita Perché che cosa facciamo
piangiamo strilliamo e quindi quello è
il momento in cui diciamo io esisto sono
vivo ci sono Mi sto aprendo alla vita e
anche per gli altri no strillare
piangere appena nati è sintomo di buona
salute Insomma si dice si dice questo e
quindi è il primo suono che mettiamo il
primo suono che sentiamo e poi ci
affezioniamo alle voci dei nostri cari
che diventano voci familiari appunto No
perché sono quelli che ci trasmettono le
emozioni
e questo è quello che spesso capita
Forse in maniera un po' forzata però con
il doppiaggio i doppiatori noi magari ci
affezioniamo alle voci degli attori che
che conosciamo bene e
poche perché ci trasmettono le emozioni
perché ci fanno vivere delle avventure
assurde no attraverso il grande o il
piccolo schermo e quando ci cambiano la
voce all'attore al nostro attore
preferito è strano capitano spesso e
abbiamo quel senso di smarrimento un po'
E pensate sia i nostri familiari sia un
nostro caro perché poi diventano quasi
dei nostri amici no gli attori i
personaggi a cui siamo affezionati
Pensate se ai nostri cari cambiassero la
voce il giorno vi svegliate C'è mamma
parla con un'altra voce farebbe strano
non sembrerebbe più lei forse
addirittura parlate al telefono con un
vostro parente a un'altra voce non non
sembrerebbe più lui
quindi la voce si identifica la voce
dalla nostra personalità la voce fa
uscire tutto quello che abbiamo dentro
non è l'unico modo di esprimersi per
carità Però una grande percentuale delle
nostre espressioni
viene attraverso la voce pensate che se
con la mia voce esperimento con la voce
di Insomma del mio personaggio di Peter
dovessi interpretare delle delle frasi
iconiche dei film famosissimi che tutti
amiamo
abbiamo delle slide credo di essermi
scordato il telecomando Torno subito
ce lo lancia il nostro lui adesso il mio
nuovo supereroe è a lui Grazie Ti voglio
bene bella applauso
dovevo scordarmi qualcosa era scritto e
bene Abbiamo adesso una slide già che è
questa Quindi se io dicessi con la mia
voce Al mio segnale scatenate l'inferno
sono Bond James Bond
No
non mi sto impegnando tanto a farle
magari le farei un po' meglio però per
farvi capire ohana significa famiglia e
Famiglia significa che nessuno deve
essere abbandonato dimenticato Questa
cosa devo fare in realtà Cioè però vabbè
non lo faccio e
non è Leviosa è Leviosa sentite che non
hanno se non le identifichiamo con
quelle voci con cui le conosciamo non
arrivano
sei solo chiacchiere e distintivo questa
La sapete insieme a me il mio tesoro
pure quest'altra La sapete
Adriana
Insomma sembro matto e un po' Lo sono
però insomma non avrebbero la stessa
forza Ecco quindi i personaggi a cui noi
siamo affezionati hanno quella forza
anche grazie alle loro voci non solo
quelli italiane chiaramente per noi in
Italia magari chi li vede in italiano sì
E
visto che siete stati abbastanza bravi
ma vorrei coinvolgervi un po' di più per
farvi capire quanto è potente la voce
Quanto può essere anche uno strumento
collettivo No è bello utilizzarla
insieme
la voce nella collettività Ecco Pensate
ai concerti
uno va al concerto non solo per sentire
il proprio artista preferito ma anche
per cantare insieme a tutte le altre
persone è proprio quello che crea anche
tante emozione allo stadio Io vado
spesso allo stadio sono grande tifoso e
l'amore per la propria squadra e la
carica che bisogna dare ai giocatori si
esprime attraverso la voce ti fanno i
cori da stadio perché si fanno i cori da
stadio perché la voce è uno strumento
potentissimo si dice che chi gioca in
casa con il proprio tipo ha più
possibilità di vincere no eh Per questo
perché la voce è potentissima e più
siamo è meglio è cioè se tipo io faccio
ho sempre voluto fare questa cosa eh
[Musica]
dai è facile Vabbè ho sempre voluto fare
questa cosa insomma la voce è uno
strumento molto potente e però vi voglio
raccontare una storia adesso quando mi
sono accorto che la voce era molto
potente che la mia voce era uno
strumento e la voce di tutti è uno
strumento molto potente Anzi parto
ancora prima come sono nato perché la
voce veramente è in grado di a volte di
modificare i percorsi di vita delle
persone e i destini e può creare la vita
dici perché allora io sono nato grazie
alla voce e direte Che vuol dire mio
padre era è un musicista che è un
cantautore e ha fatto per tanti anni il
selezionatore dello Zecchino d'Oro
e mio fratello Io ho un fratello che fa
anche lui dopo anche lui un grandissimo
doppiatore un cantante che non è figlio
di mio padre perché abbiamo due papà
diversi
andò a fare le selezioni del per lo
Zecchino d'Oro aveva cinque anni fu
selezionato da mio padre andò poi a
Bologna a fare lo Zecchino d'oro e vinse
lo Zecchino d'Oro con un altro bambino
con la canzone Il coccodrillo come fa
quando sentite il ritornello è la voce
di mio fratello Gabriele Patriarca e
dopodiché comincio a prendere lezioni di
canto da mio padre e in quel frangente i
miei genitori si innamorano e dopo due
anni sono cicciato io e
se mio padre non avesse saputo usare la
voce perché non avesse fatto il cantante
Se mio fratello non fosse stato tanto
intonato le maestre dell'asilo a mia
madre dissero lo porti a fare lo
Zecchino d'Oro le selezioni perché è
molto intonato
se non fosse successo questo io non
sarei mai nato era sempre pensato questa
cosa e sono quindi i sogni sono nato
grazie al coccodrillo come fa
incredibili fa molto ridere
e poi ho cominciato a capire crescendo
che avevo anche un talento innato per la
voce o forse respirando quell'ambiente
sempre di canto di recitazione eccetera
sono cresciuto un po' ha preso un po'
come una spugna e quindi mi sono
cimentato anch'io un po' per gioco fino
ad arrivare quando avevo più o meno 7
anni a fare Nemo il pesciolino Nemo che
ancora oggi è uno dei personaggi più
iconici che ho fatto se la batte giusto
con con Spidi e
mi sono reso conto della grande potenza
della voce quando sono andato per la
prima volta al cinema a riascoltarmi
bellissimo avevo sette anni quindi non è
che capivo molto però capivo Quello che
dovevo capire quando ho sentito la mia
voce uscire da quelle casse in quella
sala Greta e o quando ho visto le
persone reagire alle battute che io
dicevo ridere piangere e commuoversi
emozionarsi
ho detto ma che figo lo voglio intanto
lo voglio fare sempre cioè voglio
continuare a farlo per sempre lì l'ho
cominciato a realizzare che poteva
essere proprio una cosa mi sarei portato
per sempre e poi ho capito che Uno
scricciolo ero piccolino Non che adesso
sia Cresciuto tantissimo però ehm ero
molto piccolo e quella vocina minuscola
Ero riuscito a trasmettere delle
emozioni grandi perché Nemo poi ci fa
venire lacrimoni a tutti
quando verso la fine Nemo dice ti voglio
bene al papà cioè proprio lacrimoni
anche io Adesso se lo riguardo
e quindi ci sono ci sono piano piano ho
preso consapevolezza di quanto la voce
potesse essere potente un altro aneddoto
che vi posso raccontare quando ho
incontrato Tom Holland l'attore che è
doppio che interpreta spydy e che è
stata un'emozione grandissima a vederlo
Sì ma neanche troppo quando ha iniziato
a parlarmi in inglese e con la sua voce
sono rimasto pietrificato perché la sua
voce per me è un riferimento molto
importante Io ascolto la sua voce in
cuffia mentre doppio e devo intonarmi
molto Sono stato scelto perché riuscivo
a intonarmi molto alle sue note e quindi
per me sentire la sua voce più che
vederlo è stato un brivido incredibile e
mi sono emozionato e
la voce fa tanto la voce identifica
veramente i personaggi da da ci Aiuta
Aiuta tutti noi poi perché non è solo un
fatto dell'arte io adesso parlo
dell'arte ma
per tutti noi è uno strumento
fondamentale per esprimersi Noi siamo
legati al suono al rumore e adesso si
parla di rumore e e alle voci noi
scrolliamo video in continuazione in cui
se ci cattura anche il suono oltre che
l'immagine magari ci soffermiamo di più
mandiamo messaggi vocali perché forse
esprimerci a parole scritte non non ci
basta più a volte si può fraintendere no
i messaggi si possono pretendere non si
capisce la tonalità il modo in cui si
dice una cosa quindi la voce è
importantissima e diciamo che grazie
grazie grazie grazie
e poi ci sono persone
che si rendono conto un po' più di noi
quanto sia preziosa questa questa cosa
che abbiamo dentro che reputo un
superpotere e l'ho capito piano piano
non perché ho doppiato questo
personaggio qui ma perché
mi è capitato di vedere grazie anche ai
Social Insomma
ho cominciato a creare contenuti in cui
si vedeva quello che c'era dietro No il
doppiaggio dei film quindi il backstage
un po' quindi spesso capita che ci siano
molti fan varie Fiere eventi e mi sono
reso conto di quanto quando mi
cominciano a chiedere mi fai la voce di
mi saluti mi saluti mia sorella con la
voce di
io lo faccio molto volentieri tre
secondi una battuta di 5 secondi creano
crea un'emozione incredibile un sorriso
incredibile gente che si commuove a
volte o comunque felicità Perché
sentirsi salutato dal personaggio
preferito è forse è qualcosa che magari
io che lo faccio non lo capisco molto ma
capisco vedo le reazioni e questa cosa
si amplificata per esempio Sono andato
anche con Marco noctis che è il nostro
spide che avete visto prima nonostante
va un professionista molto bravo e dopo
vi presento
siamo andati spesso negli ospedali e lì
ancora di più mi sono divertito un
supereroe perché
veramente regalare un sorriso a dei
bambini davvero poco fortunati che
facendosi una piccola chiacchierata con
spider-man io mi nascondevo dietro di
lui e lui gestiva
facendo una piccola chiacchierata con
con questo personaggio
gli cambiava la giornata
Si alleviava un pochino tutta la fatica
che c'era in quei momenti e ho detto
Cavolo Un po' come un supereroe che fa
vedere un po' le sue doti fa sparare una
ragnatela magari in questo caso è c'è
chi rimane a bocca aperta si crea una
magia io con la voce posso fare questo è
una potenza incredibile e lo possiamo
fare un po' tutti in realtà
e poi pensiamo Magari alle persone non
vedenti Io ho un amico che si chiama
Davide Pigliacelli che è un bravissimo
cultore del doppiaggio è un appassionato
di doppiaggio ha scritto saggi a un sito
sul doppiaggio e
lui o non vedente che Si appassiona dal
doppiaggio perché è l'unico modo che ha
per godersi per vedere i film e grazie
alle nostre voci riesci a vedere un film
a immedesimarsi nella storia a vivere
dell'avventura sentire le atmosfere
magiche insieme anche Ovviamente tutti
gli effetti sonori e questo augurio mi
sono sentito importante per qualcuno e
per lui la voce è vitale la voce che
ascolta è vitale
e questo tutto questo dove voglio
arrivare per farvi capire che noi dentro
di noi abbiamo questo piccolo
superpotere e
nel mio caso il mio mestiere è la voce
ma nell'arte in generale un po' tutti
gli artisti hanno dei piccoli
superpoteri no Magari il corpo per una
stanza per un ballerino le mani per un
disegnatore per un pianista musicista e
sono tutte
cose che abbiamo dentro che servono a
trasmettere emozioni cose innate che
sono umane sono umane e devono rimanere
tali
perché pare che ultimamente Insomma
alcune emozioni vengono generate dal da
un'intelligenza artificiale possano
sostituire quelle umane quelle create
dall'intelletto e dal cuore e questo
secondo me non deve non dobbiamo
permetterlo e dico Dobbiamo perché
abbiamo tutti noi in mano un po' questa
questa decisione perché la tecnologia
non si può arrestare e io sono uno
amante della tecnologia io non mi alzo
neanche dal divano per spegnere le luci
col telefono anzi con con il comando
vocale Insomma sono amante della
tecnologia Però fino a un certo punto
nell'arte no nell'arte secondo me non
non può succedere e alcuni persone
vogliono che succeda e se noi
permettiamo e il pubblico è importante
in questo perché il pubblico può
decidere
e se noi permettiamo che l'arte diventi
artificiale è proprio una cosa
impensabile Perché niente può ricreare
quello che noi viviamo dentro e che
riusciamo a trasmettere attraverso la
voce o altri o altri modi Quindi quello
che vi dico è riflettete su questo
perché abbiamo in mano tutti questa
decisione veramente e niente che L'arte
non può essere artificiale Io adesso
chiudo presentandovi il nostro
amichevole spyder di quartiere che è
Marco noctis che è stato bravissimo e
anche lui è un artista che con il corpo
riesce a fare delle cose e anche nel suo
campo C'è questo rischio Quindi su tante
cose l'intelligenza artificiale la
tecnologia ci può elevare ci può far
Marco noctis un bel applauso
ci puoi levare ci può far migliorare la
nostra vita però sull'arte ragazzi
l'arte deve rimanere umana Mi raccomando
Grazie
Grazie mille